[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's now at
the point where he's leaking things
about movies after they've released
since discussing our daniel craig balder
the brave and moto scoop last week we've
been featured in comicbook.com new
rockstars mcu direct the bloody lot of
them everything is coming at milhouse
and after this week's weekly planet
discussing more of the cameos that were
cut from the multiverse of madness i
thought i'd talk about what i'd heard
was originally in the film more like
multiverse of midness hey actually i
actually like the movie so cut that got
that
i think a lot of this stuff was removed
for the pandemic or just to keep the
movie more streamlined either way as
reported over the weekend daniel craig
was originally supposed to be in the
film and he was then later replaced in
reshoots with john krasinski deadlines
justin kroll say that he was originally
meant to be reed richards and that craig
ended up pulling out because of covert
risks which meant that he would
potentially bring the virus back to his
family after just a couple of days
shooting krull has a really good
reputation and i don't think the guy
would liar make stuff up but i do think
things kind of got lost in the shuffle a
bit i actually heard last year that
craig was going to be playing ball of
the brave aka thor's half brother in the
comics slash film reported that craig
was actually in the running to play thor
all the way back in 2008 but they stated
that he turned down the role this
article is from way back when and it
goes over why he stepped back from the
project it definitely paints out the
idea that he could have been the norse
god which this movie would of course
followed up upon craig of course played
james bond and potentially he didn't
want to do two franchise characters
especially his marvel studios hadn't
really made a name for themselves then
they were just coming off the back of
iron man and it would be years before
they established themselves as the
biggest franchise in hollywood so cray
coming back as boulder makes way more
sense and it shows a sort of what if
over what could have been this is
similar to the tom cruise rumors and
they really picked up steam because he
was originally who would have played
tony stark so craig coming back is
really nice casting to me and i think
balder would have been great to have
been in the movie especially if he was
playing the role if i am wrong and he
was read then i actually prefer
krazynski over him and potentially this
could show that marvel have made up
their mind on him playing the character
in the 616. i don't see why they'd bring
in a completely different character if
they didn't want him especially for reed
but let me know below what you think and
also hit the thumbs up button please sir
peace i'm begging now as for how i heard
baldo went out i was told he was talked
into ending his own life by wonder which
is what starred the fight in the final
cut it was black bolt who died first
after he blew his own mind and then she
moved over to reed now olson actually
revealed that she'd never met krazinski
before and i think this confirms that he
was a replacement in the reshoots i
talked about this recently over at the
agents of fandom podcast and josh from
den of nerds brought out that it looks
like krazynski was just green screen
into all the footage he said that he
thinks that marvel made it as easy as
they could for him and just let him
probably film this stuff either in his
home or near it and that they just
dropped this into the scene not sure how
it works here but something to bear in
mind when you watch this stuff anyway
the weekly planet released an episode on
monday in which they discussed the
things that they'd been sent i actually
got told this recently as well but i
didn't report on it as i didn't want to
seem mental so blame them yet blame them
if mickey comes around with the goons to
tell you to stop watching this now they
start by saying the wonder killing mcu
mortal scene is real
also i can't really do the accent now
they also said that michael fassbender
was going to show up as magneto at one
point and according to their source this
scene was filmed it's something that my
time to shine hello also discussed and i
had heard his scenes were in the film
but they were later removed as the x-men
plan hasn't fully been nailed down yet i
would have loved to have seen him pop up
but perhaps with patrick stewart
appearing as well it just kind of
muddied things a bit and had people
questioning why x isn't using the
anti-aging cream that m is now there's
also the fact in the comics that magneto
is wander's father e mcallen actually
made a really fun post the other day
talking about wonder being his daughter
now magneto is in my top three villains
in the comics and though i would have
loved to have seen him in the film i can
see why he was cut from it this movie
really has no fat and i think marvel
studios in the end probably wanted to
keep the focus on the characters rather
than the cameos a lot of expectations
around comic book movies like this seems
to be purely on the cameos rather than
the story so potentially they wanted to
kind of keep perception a certain way so
that people's expectations going into
these films aren't who's going to be
popping up on top of this james and may
so also discussed a ghost rider cameo
that was supposed to be in the film they
say that he was part of the illuminati
but i heard slightly different info not
calling them liars mate yeah i'm not
calling them liars cop calm down go on
the phone anyway i heard there was going
to be a fight between him and wonder but
that this would take place in another
location away from the illuminati
headquarters at one point in the movie
we do see america in strange past
through several worlds one of which is a
hellscape with skeletons climbing up
walls and bones littering the floor this
is like it's been ripped out of a mortal
kombat fighting arena and i think this
kind of area would have been the perfect
place to have them face off against each
other but i don't know i don't know mate
if that would have happened just just
calm down now i'm not sure who would
have played him but potentially this
could have been the cage or they might
have linked it back to agents of shield
also could have potentially just been a
fully cgi character but hopefully we get
more details on this as time goes on
they then went on to discuss a cameo
that we talked about in our last plot
leak this cameo itself turned out to be
untrue but the rest of the video lined
up heavily with what we got in the end
so it makes me think there was indeed a
plan in place to either shoot this scene
or that it was at least discussed at
some point those weekly whack-a-doos
mentioned that ryan reynolds was going
to appear as deadpool in the final kill
of the movie and that he would show up
in the post-credits scene after breaking
through one of the multiversal doorways
at the illuminati headquarters going
back to the 838 scenes we watched as the
616 wonder ended up letting go of the
control she had over the one in that
universe she then jumped back into the
gap junction doorway but she left it
open meaning that there could be a way
to travel into the a38 universe this
door was previously only accessible to
those with the watch key but now anyone
who makes it into the gap junction can
potentially also travel into this
reality potentially this could cause an
incursion itself as the gap junction
might even start to bleed into the a38
reality there are lots of fan theories
that the 616 and 838 universes might end
up being pulled together in an incursion
and this would lead to a multiversal war
between the two realities as they fight
to survive i think this would be great
and currently there's a lot of talk on
twitter that this could be a way marvel
2 avengers vs x-men you'd have the a3a
x-men versus the avengers from the 616
and hey i wouldn't be mad if that's how
it went down now other things we know
from what's been released on the movie
is that we were going to meet defender
wong in the 838 universe and this may
have happened at the sanctuary i also
have a leaked scene that i can't really
talk about because i'd get in trouble
but let's say there was a moment in
mobius of madness that would have blown
the roof off at theaters around the
world oh crap crap it's leaking stop
stop
the illuminati will see you now meet the
doctor
[Applause]
anyway there was of course the final
chair at the illuminati headquarters
that never got filled though this was
said to belong to supreme strange motto
ends up taking his seat and michael
waldron actually addressed this mystery
with the hollywood reporter he said that
they want to leave her open for the
future and actually did a joke that
someone on set just put an extra chair
in there by accident
you're fired for doing that now i do
think this originally had a member in it
and then marvel just decided to kind of
tease more things for this universe down
the line potentially this was balder or
maybe even neymar who was meant to be in
the lineup but fergie decided that he
should be kept back so that his debut
could be in black panther 2. personally
i think it belonged to kevin spoilers
and it's not like i've talked enough in
this video for that not to be the case
anyway glad someone else came up before
me and said all this stuff because i've
been sitting on this for a while like
should i talk about this am i gonna look
mental always nice when someone jumps in
the grenade for you first and definitely
go check out the other channels and
websites i mentioned in this video as
you might have even ended up tom
cruising for a bruising but in the
meantime let me know below which cameo
you would have wanted to see the most we
are in a competition right now and
giving away three copies of the batman
on the 15th of june and all you have to
do to be when the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers you want some emails to
watch them make sure you check our
deleted scenes video for the film which
will be linked on screen right now talk
about a lot of things we didn't address
in this one as i didn't just want to be
repeating myself repeating myself so go
check it out right after this without
the way thanks for sending through the
video i've been poor let's see in the
next one take care peace